we cannot save everybody we just can't
that's not true for just blacks but for
all of america
but what we can do
today is awaken the spirit of aspiration
especially among the poor
[Music]
can you believe it that's right i'm
still here living inside this tent for
100 days from november 20th to february
28th bring to you the awareness that you
need to know about the violence on the
south side of chicago but also to raise
as much money as possible to build a
community center on this much needed
block called o block it's called oh
block because it's named after a young
man named od perry who was shot and
killed the gangs picked up the o in his
name and started calling it oh block we
decided we're going to keep the oath but
we're going to change it to opportunity
block i want to thank fox for giving me
the opportunity every day to come to you
and give you my thoughts and viewpoints
my own
uh
points of view as it relates to what's
going on in chicago and around our great
country today i want to talk to you
about something that is very dear to my
heart
the reason why we need school choice
on the south side of chicago is in one
word
aspiration
that word may not sound like a whole lot
but it is the key word
america is an aspirational nation we
aspire to be somebody we aspire to
create we aspire to be better
the american dream at its core is
aspirational
the problem is that many families here
on the south side are not allowed to or
not given the tools to aspire
make no mistake there are those families
that aspire no matter what
they refuse to accept the failing school
in their neighborhood and they make
great sacrifices to get their kids into
a better school
even if it means driving over an hour to
get there they do it
but not every family is able to do that
and unfortunately
there are many of them
we want to change the culture and its
values in this neighborhood by teaching
them how to aspire to be better
this is not a new lesson by any means
in fact
it was a huge part of our history and we
lost our connection to it
blaming on the post-60s liberalism which
moved
us away from the culture of aspiration
to the culture of dependency
that defines the black underclass even
to this day
i'm a student of thomas shaw and one of
my favorite stories of his is one that
he tells about dunbar high school in
washington dc
today it is one of the worst schools in
america but that was not always the case
from 1870 that's five years after the
civil war ended to 1955 dunbar was the
best all-black public school in d.c
by 1899 the school had made so much
progress despite slavery not being that
long ago and despite segregation being
the law of the land the school made so
much progress that since 1899 dunbar
students were coming in first in
city-wide test-giving in both black and
white schools
seoul wrote that many of these dunbar
graduates
could only afford to attend
low-cost colleges such as howard
university at that time in minor
teachers college
however that were done by graduates who
attended harvard amherst overland and
many other great colleges
these students ran up impressive records
of academic success and honors
the first black general the the
discovery of blood plasma the first
black senator since reconstruction and
many more
all graduates of dunbar
then the school fell apart
in 1954 brown vs board of education
ruled that racially separated schools
were inherently unequal
in the south there was no question that
blacks were providing an adequate
inadequate education but that was not
the case of dunbar
what made the school so successful was
that
all of the aspiration and the
aspirational blacks from all over dc
could apply
it didn't matter where you lived in that
city
they had their own former school choice
and could apply to dunbar
where they could be with other
like-minded aspirational people
the unintended consequences of brown
versus the board of education was that
it turned dunbar into a neighborhood
school
very much like what we see all across
america today
all of a sudden the many blacks in dc no
longer had the choice to apply to dunbar
and you know what happened it collapsed
i think that story by seoul is so
relevant today
i've said before on earlier rooftop
revelations that we cannot save
everybody we just can't
that's not true for just blacks but for
all of america
but what we can do
today is awaken the spirit of aspiration
especially among the poor
you do that by giving them opportunities
or at the least pathways to
opportunities
and that is why i'm such a huge believer
in school
it is in my opinion the civil rights
issue of our time
and that is why i'm fighting so hard
against the politicians in my city and
state to remove the moratorium against
charter schools so that we can have
one right in project hood our community
center needs it
the glory days of dunbar may be long
gone
but its lessons are not
they are timeless
especially the lesson of aspiring to be
better
thomas saul
is the biggest advocate for school
choice today and it's an honor to follow
the path as we seek to transform the
south side for
better to be more aspirational
join me in my journey join me in the
struggle join me in the fight
as we choose school choice
over everything
as i always say
god bless you
and until tomorrow
peace
you